I only various moments in reestablishing
control over this continent and every
person
oh my allies I got anything you can
count on the ID back as soon as the
Goulburn enough with the clever plan
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones
breakdown video I just finished watching
season 7 episode 4 so let's take a
closer look at this episode the spoils
of war the episode begins at Highgarden
which is the seat of house Tyrell Jaime
Lannister and his men had just stormed
the castle and taken all of their gold
and the Lannisters are currently in a
significant amount of debt to the iron
bank so they planned on using the gold
at the Tyrells have to pay off the loans
at the crown oh and as I've stated
before whenever you can't pay off your
debt to the iron bank not only does it
cut you off from getting their support
in the future but they will also start
to fund your enemies which is something
Cersei cannot allow to happen the
Lannisters need this gold to pay off the
bank and Cersei plans on hiring an army
of sell swords for the wars to come so
far Cersei has been one step ahead of
Daenerys Targaryen in the Lannister army
even caught the Tyrells by surprise
Jaime Lannister and his men were able to
take Highgarden with relative ease and
now they are on their way back with all
the goods but as Jaime and Bronn are
loading up the wagons to head back to
King's Landing Bronn notices something
is wrong with Jaime which is strange
because Jaime should be very happy right
now because the mission was accomplished
and they barely even broke a sweat bran
as Jaime if the Queen of thorns gave him
one last prick in the balls before
saying goodbye bran has no idea what
Alan and Tyrell said to Jaime right
before she died after Jaime got inside
Highgarden he had orders to make sure
Ellen and Tyrell was killed
Cersei wanted her mutilated and strung
up in King's Landing but Jaime made sure
she was given a more painless death so
he gave Alana tyrell some poison that
would make her fade to black a little
bit easier but before she died she
revealed to Jaime the truth about
Joffrey's death Alanna Tyrell wasn't
about to allow Cersei to get the last
laugh so she told Jaime to tell Cersei
that she was the one who poisoned her
son who died pretty damn violently and
that is why Jamie is having a bad day
but he isn't about to tell bran dad as
they are loading things up
Jaime hands bran a satchel full of gold
coins for his help but Bryan isn't
entirely satisfied bran wants to be
given Highgarden to and the reason why
bran ones Highgarden is because Jaime
Lannister offered him a bigger castle if
he helped him sneak into Dorne and get
his and Circe's daughter Marcella out of
there safely although Marcella was
poisoned by the sand snakes before she
could ever make it home safely bran
still did live up to his end of the deal
and Jaime has promised him a bigger
castle for a very long time
Jamie isn't about to give him Highgarden
and he makes a very good point why Jamie
knows Daenerys will want revenge for
this and bran would never be able to
defend himself there when she comes it's
a good thing Jamie got him to reconsider
because Daenerys was definitely on her
way for some payback
Jamie promises bran that he could have
any Castle he wants after the war is
over but there is no telling when that
could be and when Cersei sitting on the
Iron Throne the realm will never really
be at peace before the scene ends
Jamie sends brought off with Randall and
Dickon Tarly to make sure they get all
the crops that they will need to keep
his men and horses fed for the many wars
to come in the next scene we go to the
red keep where Sochi Lannister and tyka
from the iron banker discussing the
current debt Cersei assures him that the
money is on its way in Jaime Lannister
is escorting the gold himself
Cersei actually plans on paying off this
outrageous amount of debt in one payment
and she also has plans of beefing up her
army and navy she is not going to rest
until the Seven Kingdoms are secured the
iron bank has every intention of helping
Cersei as long as the gold arrives she
is currently in a great position and I
have to admit Cersei has been amazing so
far this season as of right now she is
my MVP of the season she continues to
make the right moves while planning for
the future
her plan has been foolproof up until
this point and it's going to be
interesting to see how things unfold if
Cersei does end up getting an army of
cell swords and a larger fleet if
Daenerys starts to lose any of her
dragons then Cersei has a real shot at
winning this war against her although
the Lannisters get the [ __ ] kicked out
of them at the end of this episode and
most importantly the war against the
army of the dead is still to come next
we go up north to Winterfell where
little [ __ ] and bran stark are having
a private conversation Littlefinger
pulls out the Valyrian steel dagger that
was used during an assassination attempt
to kill bran stark all the way back in
season one after bran witnessed Jaime
and Cersei having sex
Jaime pushed him out of the tower window
hoping he would fall to his death but
when he survived someone tried to take
his life again there are many theories
surrounding this second attempt that was
taken on branes life some say Joffrey
put the hit on bran stark open it would
place his fake father Robert Baratheon
while others say Littlefinger was
actually behind the hit either way the
Valyrian steel blade has made its way
back to Winterfell
since Littlefinger stole it from Ned
Stark's office after he had him set up
to get arrested by the Kingsguard
Littlefinger is acting like he is
showing a sign of
faith by giving this valerian still to
brand but we all know he doesn't do
something for someone unless he thinks
it can help him in his position in some
way bran - Littlefinger if he knows who
this blade belonged to but Littlefinger
says no but I think bran may have been
testing his honesty here and
Littlefinger failed miserably
I believe bran does know Littlefinger
knows where it came from which leads to
something brand does later what this
dagger Littlefinger does acknowledge the
fact that brain may have seen some
things that most men wouldn't believe
but Littlefinger is referring to
everything that lies beyond the wall
that brain may have seen during his
travels Littlefinger has no idea what
brain has actually seen and these things
may end up leading to Littlefinger's
death
Littlefinger tells brand that it's
ashame brain has finally made it back
home and now all this chaos is going on
in the world but bran cuts him off and
says chaos is a ladder which is the
exact same thing Littlefinger said to
Varys many seasons ago what brain says
gets little fingers full attention and
he has to be wondering why the hell bran
would say something like this bran
obviously knows a few things about
Littlefinger that he probably doesn't
want people knowing Littlefinger has
finally met his match
brain is someone that actually knows
more than Littlefinger does and for once
Littlefinger is feeling extremely
vulnerable right now this just got very
interesting and Littlefinger will soon
come to find out that he will not be
able to outmaneuver someone that can see
the moves he plans to make Littlefinger
gets up to leave as Meera Reed walks in
the room and he says I am sorry to have
disturbed you Lord Stark but bran tells
him he is not Lord Stark because brain
has no intentions in ruling the north
he wouldn't even be able to rule but the
way that his mind now works bran is too
disconnected and detached from everyone
else and he has a much larger role to
play and can't be bothered with the
day-to-day duties of running the north
mirror comes in to tell bran that she is
leaving but Bryan already knows this
mirror says that she would stay with him
but she wants to be with her family when
the army of the Dead comes she probably
doesn't expect to survive the winter now
that bran is home Meera feels like her
mission is complete she got brand to the
three-eyed Raven and she even got him
back home she was expecting a little bit
more of a pleasant goodbye from brand
but he has became so detached that he
really doesn't know how to interact with
anyone without coming off as an [ __ ]
no one fully understands brains mental
capacity at this moment bran does tell
Meera thank you
for helping me but she was expecting
more because her brother died for this
Hodor and some are even died for him but
bran is still pretty much emotionless
the problem is we can't fully understand
what is going on inside his mind just
yet so I can't be mad at bran for the
way that he has been acting both of his
parents are dead his best friend died to
protect him and he just saw his uncle
who is now a half zombie and he has the
entire weight of the realm resting on
his shoulders and he knows it's going to
be up to him to figure out how to end
this long night bran may have witnessed
his own death or he may have even
witnessed his brother and sisters deaths
that are still yet to come
he might be having visions of the night
king slaughtering everyone at Winterfell
so I can't judge him now for the way
that he is acting because I do not know
what is going on inside of his head if
anyone else has seen what he has seen
they would probably be acting the same
way bran will never be brain again now
that he is the three-eyed Raven he will
still look the same but he will never
act the same again but let's move on to
happier times in the next scene we
finally see Arya Stark making it home as
she sits on her horse overlooking
Winterfell I know I said this in my last
video but this is a beautiful shot right
here as she looks over the property Orie
then makes her way to the gate and these
[ __ ] won't let her in little do they
know that she could carve them both up
into little pies if they weren't stark
bannermen they do allow her to come
inside the gate and wait while they go
and find songs of when Arya sits down I
liked how she just kind of looked around
the courtyard and soaked it all in
having the realization that she has
finally made it home to a place she
probably thought she would never see
again while the guards argue over who
will tell Lady Sansa
Arya uses her ninja-like faceless men
skills and dashes out to the crypts to
see her family the men go tell songs are
that someone is there claiming to be
Arya Stark and when they tell songs as
she was asking about maester Luwin and
sir Roderick she knows right away it's
Arya because not too many people would
be asking about men that have been dead
for a very long time and she already
knows where Arya would be so then we cut
to our second stark reunion this season
but I have to say Arya didn't seem as
excited to see sauna as Sansa did seeing
her when songs that came up to give her
a hug Orie I just kind of looked at her
like what are you doing you can see just
how dark Arya is now she is also a
little bit detached from some of her
emotions but just not as bad as brand
it's funny because Arya asked her if she
has to call her
lady Stark because she knows that Sansa
always wanted to be in this kind of
position she even wanted to be queen
Sansa tells Aria she shouldn't have ran
from the guards but Aria makes a very
good point they need better guards those
guards sucked we did get a nice smile
out of Aria though when Saunders says
John will be even more excited to see
her again
than he did seeing her and we all know
how much John and Aria love each other
when those to reconnect I will probably
cry like a little [ __ ] but I don't care
Shana then finds out about Aria's little
hit list that she has been keeping all
of these years after aria asks aunt if
she was the one who actually killed
Joffrey Cersei has blamed Songza for
playing a role in his death and news has
spread everywhere
Cersei still won songs his head on a
spike what's Littlefinger said he would
help Cersei see the lion fly over
Winterfell Songza tells Aria that she
didn't kill Joffrey but she does wish
that she did Arya said that no matter
how long her less gut Joffrey was always
first and so on to kind of laughs it off
as if Arya isn't being serious but we
all know Arya is very serious if she had
the right opportunity she would have
killed Joffrey she was ready to kill him
all the way back in season one I really
like what happens next they both ask
each other how they got home and they
both say it's not a very pleasant story
but then Aria says their stories aren't
over just yet and I really like that
line and Arya really liked that songs
agreed and it kind of got Arya to let
her guard down a little bit and she
actually reaches out and pulls songs in
for a hug and she smiles it was really
nice to see these two embrace each other
after all this time and all that they
have been through Songza tells Aria that
brain is home to an aria is very happy
to hear this but Songza doesn't smile
she knows how broken brain is and Aria
can tell that something must be wrong
with bran by the expression on Songz's
face so they go outside to see him
sitting alone in the gods but at the
weirwood tree aria is very happy to see
bran she even gives him a big hug but
brain is nearly emotionless once again
he tells Arya that he knows she was at
the crossroads and he knows that she
planned on going to King's Landing to
kill the Queen
Sansa now knows Arya wasn't kidding
about her hit list
Arya truly intended on killing every
single one of them on that list
bran then pulls out the dagger that
Littlefinger gave to him and songs and
knows right away that Littlefinger did
this to benefit himself hoping
to gain brands trust but I don't see
that happening with bran
he knows Littlefinger is up to no good
brain ends up giving the dagger to Arya
and he says he doesn't need it because
he is a [ __ ] and can't use it but I
believe he gave it to Arya for another
reason
I believe brain tested Littlefinger when
he asked him if he knew who the dagger
belonged to and when Littlefinger lied
and said he didn't that sealed his fate
and brains eyes so bran gave the dagger
to arya knowing that she will use this
dagger to kill him bran knows what's up
because he probably seen this happen
already in his mind and he knows she
would be the one to carry it out the
three starts then go back inside the
main courtyard of Winterfell and I gotta
say I really love seeing this scene
seeing all three of them together
Podrick and Brienne see them as they are
coming in and Podrick tells Brienne that
lady Catelyn would have been proud
because she kept her vow Sansa and Arya
are now home safe
but Brienne tries to dismiss what
Podrick said because she doesn't feel
like she really did enough mostly
because Arya made it home on her own but
I don't care what anyone says Brienne
worked her ass off trying to get these
kids home she went toe-to-toe with the
Hound so she could escort Arya home
herself she stared at a tower for months
just waiting for a sign that Songza was
in serious trouble then she killed
several Bolton men to keep Songza from
being taken back to Ramsay it might not
have went according to plan but Brienne
did her jobs a shout out to bran for
putting in that work and still holding
it down to this day Littlefinger watches
from above as the Starks make their way
into the castle
Littlefinger's knows that with all the
Starks getting together his chances of
getting any kind of control or influence
over songs in the north is getting less
and less by the day his time is
beginning to run out and he knows he's
going to need to devise some kind of
scheme to work his way back into the
fold as Littlefinger is watching over
them the raven that is next to him makes
a noise and you can see little fingers
eyes start to shift but it's very subtle
and i think that may have been a sign
that Littlefinger is thinking about
sending out a raven to someone so he can
put forward a new plan to strengthen his
position and possibly turn his back on
saw ensue next we get a quick scene of
some pillar talk about the masane day in
Daenerys but John has shifted through so
it's quickly interrupted they go down
into the caves where John plans on
mining the dragonglass but further back
in the cave John shows Daenerys some
paintings left by their children of the
forest
it's paintings of the children and the
first men fighting together against a
common end
the White Walkers John uses this as a
point to show Daenerys that they will
need to band together if they plan on
surviving the winter he wasn't lying
about the army of the Dead
it's real it's always been real Daenerys
does believe John now and she even
agrees to help but he must bend the knee
first but John knows if he lays down and
accepts a Targaryen as his queen the
north will be outraged
Daenerys doesn't quite understand just
how hated the Targaryen czar in the
north but she still believes if John
would support her then the rest of his
men would fall in line but it's not that
simple I think if everyone in the north
could meet Daenerys and see what kind of
person she is they might be a little bit
more open-minded and if everyone in the
north actually saw the army of the dead
for themselves then they too would know
that they are going to need the support
and help from any and everyone even a
Targaryen in their dragons especially
their dragons soon enough they are going
to learn that they need to get over this
Daenerys does say something very
interesting the John Doe before they
leave the caves when John says he can
bend the knee because of what his people
would think Daenerys says isn't their
survival more important than your pride
and this is almost exactly what Varys
says did Ned when he was locked in the
cells in King's Landing Ned was put in
the same position to try and save his
daughters sometimes you have to tuck
that pride for the betterment of others
and this is something John will end up
having to do as well just like Ned did
when he had to swear fealty to Joffrey I
thought this was a very interesting
parallel with John and Ned once again as
John and Daenerys come out the cave they
are greeted by Tyrion and Varys
Daenerys learns that the unsullied has
taken Casterly Rock but it pretty much
meant nothing because the Lannisters
were already gone taking a much more
important Castle at Highgarden not only
did they get the gold in the food but
they knocked off another one of the
nurses big allies in Daenerys is pissed
while she has been sitting on her ass at
Dragonstone the Lannisters and Euron
have been chipping away at our alliances
one by one strengthening their position
it's safe to say that Tyrians plan did
not work he was outmaneuvered by his own
brother and sister and Daenerys even
questions if Tyrion is actually trying
as hard as he could be or is he actually
trying to protect his family she does
make a fair point because you have to
wonder how motivated Tyrion actually is
knowing this could end up getting Jaime
killed who he still loves dearly but
it's time to cut the clever plans and
are taking over with fire and blood
Daenerys was so pissed it kind of got me
excited she was ready to take her
dragons right into downtown King's
Landing and start burning [ __ ] and I
loved it
Daenerys could win this war right now
with her dragon power but she will not
win two people if she does it this way
but if she wants to defeat Cersei right
now her only move is to smoke her ass
out of the red keep Daenerys is torn and
she doesn't know exactly what to do so
she actually asked John for his advice
what she was reluctant to give but he
knew he had to say something or else she
was going to react out of blind rage
John told her she can't go burning them
all or else she would be just like her
father she is going to have to play the
long game if she wants to do it right
and it's going to be interesting to see
if Daenerys can keep her patience and
refrain from going mad and torching
everything but for now she accepts John
antarians advice about not burning down
King's Landing but it's not going to
stop her from torching the lannister and
Tarly armies out in the open field by
the time this episode ends next we go
back to Winterfell where Podrick is
getting his ass kicked once again by
Brienne I know I've said this before but
I'm going to say it again
they keep showing us these training
scenes with Podrick and Brienne and I
think that's because one day Podrick
will eventually use his skills to kill
someone important or even a white Walker
during their training Oriya approaches
them eager to test her own skills
against bran but Bryan isn't aware of
how good Arya actually is so she's
worried about training with her herself
but Arya is cocky as hell when she tells
Brienne don't worry I won't cut you I
really love this scene Arya look so
graceful and smooth and the only way
Brienne was actually going to be able to
stop her was by using Herbert strength
what she did when she kicked arya and
put her flat on her back but Arya is
tough as nails and she hopped right back
up like she was the Karate Kid now I
know neither one of them were actually
trying their hardest but I believe Arya
could have killed Breen if she really
wanted to similar to how Oberyn could
have against a mountain they are so fast
it's nearly impossible to stop without a
gun I also loved how they scene ended
though when Brienne asked her who taught
her and Arya says no one Brienne thinks
she was just being funny but we all know
who Arya really means the camera then
pans up the Psalms and Littlefinger who
I've been watching them the whole time
songs that kind of takes a deep
breath and walks away and there is
actually two ways you can look at this
song as it was either jealous of this or
she was kind of disturbed by it but how
good aria is or the person she turned
out to be either way song as it didn't
like what she saw and Littlefinger was
surprised by this too he must know aria
is not someone he can play games with an
aria gives him a cold stare letting him
know she definitely isn't someone he can
play with and she knows about your
little secret meeting with Tywin
Lannister back on Dragonstone Davos and
John take a walk and talk about Daenerys
Davos knows John is starting to have
feelings for her but John pretends he
doesn't have the time for that trust me
John there is always time for that it's
not like you're spending every single
minute of the day planning for the
future we then get a call back to
Stannis Baratheon here when John talks
about the number of men they have in
Dolphus corrects him by saying the word
fewer Davos is a quick learner sharpest
attack they run into missandei during
their walk and missandei asked John
about his last name where she comes from
they don't take on a bastard name like
John had - John says his last name is
snow because his mother and father
weren't married but this may have been
some foreshadowing because we may find
out later that John's parents were
married which would make him a
legitimate Targaryen and rightful heir
to the Iron Throne but as of right now
John still knows nothing John and Davos
then question her about how really free
she is
she says that Daenerys did free her and
she made her an advisor but could she
really leave if she wanted to
missandei may think they were being rude
here but I think John was just trying to
see if Daenerys really can be a good
ruler John then notices a Greyjoy ship
approaching the shore and it is Theon
Greyjoy arriving after being nearly
killed by his uncle Euron Greyjoy after
the attack on the sea
Theon was not expecting to see Jon Snow
there was he beyond those there is going
to be a problem
Theon was always a smartass - Jon dating
all the way back to when they were just
kids
he was always rubbing it in John's face
that he was a bastard when Jon found
ghost
Theon basically said ghost is a runt of
the litter just like you Jon now that
father isn't around Jon really gets his
chance to get up and fianc face but fian
did saisons Assad will find a way to
work with him I was pretty happy to hear
fiance he was trying to get Daenerys his
help to get his sister back that leaves
the window open for Theon to step up and
his sister and possibly even kill his
uncle you're on in the process which is
something I had predicted he would do
but John tells Theon that Daenerys isn't
there and this is where the episode
starts to intensify as we reach the main
event of the evening we learn something
very interesting here randyll Tarly
tells Jamie that all of the gold has
made it back to King's Landing safely
through the gates and I'm going to be
honest with you I was not expecting this
to happen
I thought Daenerys was going to be able
to get here in time to stop the shipment
but apparently not that is another big
win for Cersei but before the Lannisters
can do their victory parade something
amazing happens next
bran all of a sudden here is the
thunderous sound of a stampede
containing thousands of pissed-off Death
racki that have been bloodthirsty ever
since they step foot on Westerosi soil
the Lannisters are not the only ones who
pay their debts I loved how you could
actually hear the Dothraki charging
before you could even see them and their
war cries echoed across the battlefield
making some of the Lannister soldiers
absolutely terrified what was going to
appear behind that hill Robert
Baratheon's worst nightmare was about to
come true
a tidal wave of the three key men in the
open field is not something you want
charging directly at you as Jaime
Lannister tells bran that they can hold
them off
drogon lets loose a roar louder than all
of the Lannister lions combined Jaime
now knew he was [ __ ]
Daenerys soars above the Dothraki
providing air support and she looked
pissed one of the last things some of
these Lannister men will ever hear is
Daenerys screaming the word dragged
Horace drogon opens up his release valve
and torches the front line of men which
creates a bottleneck for the Dothraki to
get behind the enemy lines and for the
next 10 minutes it's nothing but pure
carnage a bloodbath
the Dothraki carved Lannister's up like
a hot knife through butter
but that's when Jaime remembers they
have the ballista that can bring down
the dragon so he sends Bronn off to
operate it one Dothraki soldier tracks
bran down but he has a surprise waiting
for him a giant-sized error right for
his chest it was kind of a waste because
bran could have just slit his throat
once he peeked his head inside but it
was cool-looking nonetheless at some
point during this battle Jaime gets into
a 1vs1 fight against one of the Dothraki
men and right as he is about to be
overpowered he
saved by his Valyrian steel plot armor
de cantar Lee then Tyrion shows up all
of a sudden and I wasn't expecting to
see him there but he overlooks the
chaotic battlefield he knows the
Lannisters are getting slaughtered and
he's afraid Jaime might lose his life
there is also another beautiful shot
during this battle
Daenerys comes soaring across the water
on drogon and it looks really cool as
the water ripples below them as he
creeps up on the Lannister men but bran
has the ballista locked and loaded ready
to take Daenerys and the dragon down but
his first shot goes whizzing past
Daenerys his head in this startles
Tyrion because he now realizes Daenerys
is very vulnerable
Tyrion had to have been so torn inside
at this moment two people that he really
loves are on the verge of killing each
other
Tyrion does know just how good bran is
with an arrow but Daenerys scans the
ground and sees where the shot came from
but bran is already loading up for his
second shot before she can get close in
boom bran hits his target sending drogon
into a tailspin
forcing him to land in the middle of the
battlefield now Daenerys is extremely
vulnerable as she attempts to remove the
arrow from drove on shoulder Daenerys is
extremely lucky she didn't fall off of
her dragon from that height but she too
was wearing Valyrian steel plot armor as
Daenerys is pulling out the arrow Jamie
seizes his one opportunity to make a mad
dash to take them down
but Daenerys and Drogo on turned just in
time and Jamie realizes he done [ __ ]
up now
drogon opens up to unleash hell on Jaime
Lannister but once again his Valyrian
steel plot armor comes in to save the
day
aka bran and he tackles Jaime into the
water just in the nick of time as
dragons fire soars across the water
Jaime Lannister was not burnt but his
heavy-ass armor sinks him right to the
bottom and the screen begins to fade the
black as he helplessly reaches out for
help this episode ends the same way
Tyrion nearly drowned when him and Jorah
were attacked by the stone men in
valerio it does look like Jaime
Lannister could possibly die here but we
all know he is not going to die just yet
because I think he still has a much
bigger purpose to serve in season eight
this episode was outstanding the season
continues to get better and better as we
build up towards what I am sure will be
an explosive finale comment down below
and tell me what were some of your
favorite moments from the
episode what did you love what did you
hate what do you want to see happen next
once again thank you all for stopping by
and watching today's video I will be
releasing my episode 5 preview trailer
breakdown tomorrow so I hope you all
come back to watch that one too
I also want to give a special thanks to
all my patreon supporters thank you all
so much I will see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]